Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність тільки що ми почули від
колеги зі свої народу яка класна людина
Андрій холодом Ну просто зараз буду я
просто ридати що він нас покидає А я
хочу трішки нагадати Хто це це друг
родини медведчуків їхньої дружини
кумовья він 22-й номер - списку партії
слуга народа Він після виборів заступник
голови ключового комітету з питань
фінансів податкової політики в якому він
просував інтереси власного тютюнового
бізнесу бо він же кришує і є хазяєм Це
ті мафів в Києві ларьків по продажу
тютюнових виробів і не тільки холодом ще
раз кам говорю холодом був впійманий
радіо свободою на просування своїх
особистих інтересів і все було Гаразд
його далі тримали в парламенті холодів
покинув країну під час мій коронавірусу
і коли президент Зеленський закликав
всіх повернутися то холода в полетів на
Кіпр і залишився там і це стало відомо
тільки від журналістів холодів потім в
січні місяці цього року покинув Україну
взагалі на півроку і нічого не
відбувалося ніхто його не прибирав
повний мовчок Ну нема півроку народного
депутата чимось дуже зайнятий От тепер
коли почався знов суспільний розгляд
коли медіа підняли цю тему і почався
скандал від холоду вас завзяли заяву і
тепер хочуть зробити вигляд А що які
холода Тобто ви спочатку берете друга
медведчука дає тему заробити мільйони
купити нерухомість Відні на Кіпрі всюди
він валить з країни під час пандемії він
валить з країни під час війни а тепер ви
нам кажете він молодець Я вас вітаю це
фантастика він фантастичний слуга народу
ну Точно такий як всі дякую